hi everyone I'm Carolina I love
everything movies I love everything pop
culture and I'm the type of person that
when I watch movies I look at a kitchen
and I go I wish that was because
specifically Nancy Meyer kitchens okay
so today we're going to be taking this
kitchen and we're going to be
transforming it into the style of three
of my favorite movies one of course
being a Nancy Myers film it's
complicated the second being Amelie and
the third house Moving Castle now listen
I can't decorate this face by myself
luckily we have an amazing group of
women today we have Alyssa and Claire on
the art team they're going to be
transforming the space and I can't wait
to see what it looks like now let's get
to our first kitchen fancy Myers I hope
I make you proud so the first kitchen we
have today is inspired by the movie It's
Complicated it is a 2009 film by Nancy
Meyer starring Meryl Streep Alec Baldwin
Steve Martin a great cast of people dare
I say so when I first heard we were
doing a video like this I immediately
thought we have to do Nancy Meyer's
kitchen hello that's like the best parts
of her films or her sets her kitchens
and allegedly her own kitchen is quite
beautiful and spectacular Nancy please
invite me over so I can verify that
statement but it was one of those movies
that was on HBO all the time so when my
mom would watch it I would just and
watch it with her I was way too young
way too young to be watching this movie
however I loved it I love Nancy Myers
films so much The Parent Trap hello it's
like the best movie ever and this movie
in particular my favorite scene is when
Meryl Streep is making the chocolate
croissants my mom and I talk about that
scene a lot we've even attempted to make
chocolate croissants and
it just was not up to par everything
here in the kitchen for the most part is
pretty neutral the movie is set in Santa
Barbara So this aesthetic is the coastal
grandmother aesthetic you might have
remembered it as being a tick tock Trend
people were calling it also the Nancy
Myers aesthetic flowy white t-shirts
some not so skinny jeans maybe some of
those new like cute mini Uggs you know
what I'm talking about you know maybe
you're drinking your hot coffee or your
hot chocolate and you're looking out
onto your beach and you're just like
contemplating your life that's the kind
of aesthetic we were going for today so
contrary to the title it's complicated
and the messy love triangle that we see
in the film the kitchen is not
complicated it's very clean it's very
much where Meryl Streep has full control
of her life whereas everywhere else she
kind of does not this kitchen in
particular has everything a baker Chef
needs within reach the food is all on
display it's in glass coverings it's an
eyesight so you know you're in a very
good ready to eat kitchen so it's a lot
of Rattan Vibe now as much as I love a
good Coastal Kitchen it's time to swipe
this kitchen away and into the world of
a fun Parisian Amelie kitchen
Beyond venue to Amelie's kitchen who can
forget that iconic scene of her in the
movie theater where she's just like
looking straight into the camera and
then she looks back at the people Amelie
is a movie that has left such a huge
impact in my life I feel like it's an
animated film for some reason that's
what it comes across and the colors I
mean who could forget the colors of the
colors are so unique the greens the Reds
the yellows and they're all inspired by
paintings of Brazilian artist Juarez
Machado now the character of Amelie is
someone who doesn't really need lavish
things all of her Decor is very simple
it's very traditional she likes to bake
so we have things that are easy access
to bake now the clock is such an
important Motif in the film because the
narrator whenever he narrates something
there's always a specific time attached
to whatever's going on so it's smack dab
in the center of the kitchen now in the
film Amelie she has a windowsill of
plants and herbs so she can spy on her
neighbors like I do also and we paid
homage to that with these little plants
at the edge of the sink now Amelie also
has a cat if you remember the scene
where she thinks her lover is going to
come through the beat good doorway and
it's the cat and I also have a cat so we
paid homage to the cats by having the
paintings and the little statue above
the microwave now Alma loves to bring
joy to Strangers With The Gnome in the
film so we also have our own little no
that'll bring joy every time we enter
the kitchen now this kitchen like the
film is all about the little details
specifically in the coloring with the
red and the greens like I mentioned
before so we have red tables we have
green and red utensils some mugs and to
bring out some texture we have some
checkered things as well and I mean this
table is so cute and it's so reminiscent
of the tables at the cafe where Amelie
works now as much as I love this kitchen
it's time to say
and hello to Miyazaki now last but
certainly not least is the recreation of
Howl's Moving Castle and kitchen form
now I am so excited about this
transformation specifically because
Studio Ghibli films have left such a
huge impact on my life especially house
Moving Castle this is just very earthy
it feels kind of human if you will with
the heart rate there very cluttered and
it is very cluttered at the beginning of
the film until Sophie comes and kind of
cleans it all up for you so the kitchen
is inside like a really weird big Moving
Castle hence the title hell's Moving
Castle and so it's very much human it's
very cluttered I mean if a house is
moving things are going to shift things
are going to be messy and if you've seen
the film you're probably like wait I
know that little playback there so this
plate is a callback to the portal door
situation in house Moving Castle where
it gets to different places if you will
so it's a painted plate as a call back
to that how cute is that one really
awesome thing about Studio Ghibli movies
is the food the ASMR food I think is an
aspect in every single film of his when
Sophie first enters the castle there's
food everywhere because they can't
really cook without howl telling
calcifer what to do but Sophie's like no
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna boss castle
for around now one of my favorite scenes
in house Moving Castle is when Hal gets
mad at Sophie because she messes with
his potion so he picks the wrong one and
his hair changes color and I like one
has this dark hair okay so as an Ode to
all the magic potions in the castle we
have the little bottles right here super
cute what feels so special about this
kitchen is within a Moving Castle it's
very human it's very DIY it's not
Immaculate it's not clean like humans
it's messy and there you have it that
was such an incredible transformation
comment below which of the
Transformations was your favorite and
which of your favorite movies has the
best kitchen and maybe we'll get to do
it next time
thanks for watching bye